[Music]
okay hi my name is Rachel and I may be
drunk hi my name is julissa and I may be
Joe hey my name is destiny hi my name is
Lauren I'm Sarah do you want more than
that you can usually tell when
somebody's drunk because they'll slur
their sentences slip any kind of dancing
I guess I'll also be looking for signs
to see if anyone's trying to stifle
themselves and keep themselves composed
because sometimes trying to keep
yourself composed when drunk you can you
look more drunk
I'm decently okay at pretending that I'm
sober when I'm drunk I am pretty good at
like sobering up really quickly if I
have to and yeah I'm also oh wait and
then I'm gonna say okay she sells
seashells on the seashore Michelle she
sells our seashells
I'm sure so if she sells seashells on
the seashore and I'm sure she sells
seashore shell she sells seashells on
the seashore the sell she's shelves are
seashells I'm sure so if she sells
seashells on the seashore then I'm sure
she sells seashore she'll see she sells
seashells on the seashore the shells
she sells our seashells I'm sure so if
she sells she seashells on the seashore
that I'm sure she sells seashore shells
she sells seashells on the seashore the
shells she sells are she shells I'm sure
so if she sells seashells on the
seashore
then I'm sure she sells sheet or sells
shells she sells seashells on the
seashore the shells she sells our
seashells I'm sure so if she sells
seashells on the seashore then I'm sure
she sells seashore
nobody serve here to read it fast and
then do we set the back on top I have
some people like sit them out I have to
say that if one of us is wasted I'm very
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so what does this cheat one one foot oh
one foot okay you guys I can't even I'm
supposed to do one it's like I'm at the
gym like I don't know how much longer
the West
help me to beat so easily
yeah one foot is hard I'm gonna do my
right foot because it's beautiful I have
flat feet
and my right foot is a lot flatter than
[Music]
really doing it okay yoga if you are
[Music]
okay yeah you're doing I don't that was
just hard but now I don't
I duck you fuzz ducky plans does he
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy
duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck
you for supper Thank You Beth thank you
guys
does he duck fuzzy duck Yvette stuck you
for its ducky fuzz Thank You bud ducky
Pat does he fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy
that close it
buzzie deck daddy ducky fuzz ducky fuzz
she like you stepped it up and she's
killin it now here we go
me turn am I going eat this you turn
fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy duck fuzzy
duck fuzzy duck you putz Stuckey fuzz
does he that is so funny is nobody
driving Raj oh so I don't know about
this Jim it doesn't seem like the best
party Jim people son it really smiley
which is nice no take another charge
Tito's no they're gonna be like settled
I've had some I've had a bit to drink
but I think I did a good job right Hilda
[Music]